just to check them in the right room how
many of you like to make a lot more
money
excellent and how many of you would like
a lot more time also have you liked
those well turns the birds next you give
them a high five and say you're in the
right room
excellent well my name is Samuel lead
and it's great to be here this evening
I'm not 21 anymore
I'm now 26 but I'm here to talk to you
today about financial freedom and the
title of the topic is financial freedom
never made easier but as before we go
into this would it be okay if I just
take a little bit about myself as we can
we spend time together okay great I like
you guys okay well so when I was 17
years old I actually my church sent me
off on a mission trip to Africa and I
went to Kenya Tanzania and different
parts of Africa and it was absolutely
fabulous and I was doing a lot of
charity work out there and I got back to
England and it was raining and I've been
you know singing with the people
absolutely no no worries Hakuna Matata
and all this stuff and then got back and
I was working for my dad at the time for
25 pounds a day 17 years old and I was
actually an entertainer so I used to go
and do shows and things like that on
cruise ships and different stuff I
didn't particularly like it the money
wasn't very good and I got back and as I
don't have that Monday morning feeling
before yeah times that by a million and
that's what I felt and I just thought
you know I really don't want to be doing
this for the rest of my life how many
how many no I'm talking about yes thank
you now you're um so I read a book that
somebody gave me called which Dad Poor
Dad
my um I'd live with my real daddy's not
poor but but I was always fascinated by
the title and I read the book
and as a result of that I don't know
exactly how but I ended up at a property
networking event hosted by the man
himself Simon's ishe now this is back in
around about 2007 and I think there was
only about three pin
eating's across the country and I turned
up and felt completely out of place like
a kid in a suit you know like really
really out of place fish out of water
and you know the open networking that
goes on beforehand that must be like the
worst thirty minutes of my life people
would come up to me and say so what's
your strategy then and I was like oh
bright red in the face you know feeling
where I had no idea but Simon sushi he
spoke he talked about buying properties
using other people's money and other
people's knowledge and all this stuff
and I thought well maybe I could do this
and I was really excited and I said to
Simon afterwards I'm going to do this
I'm really excited thank you so much and
I got back home and I told a couple
people and I remember being around the
dinner table at a family get-together
and and it was a nice because it bother
at this point I don't say I quit my job
you know I just quit my job straight
away because of course you know this was
going to work out right Simon said it
was it was doable and anyone could do it
so of course it's gonna work out so I
quit my job to be a property investor
and I remember that moment around the
table and my cousin he said to me so you
were a property investor now then I said
yeah he said so how many houses do you
have and I just felt ashamed any
barriers you know I'm I've quit my job
to be a property investor I'm 17 I have
no money and have no houses yeah I'm
selling my property investor and I just
thought you know what maybe this is a
pipe dream this is this is not really
going to be for me maybe I'll wait 10 20
years and then I got a phone call off
Simon Boucher and we on the phone about
45 minutes and he basically said Samuel
you can do this and he said Samuel I
believe in you I'm 17 years old and from
that point on I thought you know what
I'm going to do this I'm going to give
it a crack so these were back in the
days when if you were to I mean I don't
know how many of you investing for quite
some time okay also how many of you are
pretty new to this how many of your
property investors but don't have any
houses yet that's okay you're in the
right place so but back in the day what
kind of like the strategy that was that
was going around was that you would find
a property
and maybe for example the asking price
and valuably 120,000 pounds and you
would negotiate the price down to maybe
how much I'm just checking you can see
if you don't say anything I'm going to
have to write a lot bigger how much
bling pandu it thank you usually go
straight to buy it that'll be the
purchase price for a hundred thousand
pounds and then you would very quickly
maybe the same day or the next day we
financed it back up to its true value
120 you'd pull your money out and
effectively it'll be a no money down
deal then on remember these days yeah
that was how I bought my first house and
I'm not going to spend too much time
going into it because since then the
rules have changed a little bit haven't
they yes okay I say a little bit they've
changed a lot so I bought my first house
like this now I couldn't get a mortgage
so I I put the property in my brother's
name and bought him a drink I borrowed
the money cash and refined out to get
actually that same day and you can go
right move and you can find the address
and you can see it was bought on the
29th of March for 120 and then the next
day it's really cool and I was like oh
my gosh I've got my first house now from
this property I rented it out room by
room and the mortgage payments were 166
and the rent was 1400 I thought yeah
this is really this is great
I had a few expenses and some bills but
pretty much from that house alone and
this was the week after my 18th birthday
I was trying to set up for life so I was
like great so I'm what I did was I
didn't think about doing what's more the
rules change they said you can no longer
refinance the same day and all this
stuff but I just kind of thought okay
that's fine but you know what I'm making
the grand a month profit which is the
same as my friends will make in but I'm
doing nothing for it because the rents
could' every month great so I climbed up
Kilimanjaro
I recorded an album I went and did
recorded in a singing album if you
YouTube Samuel lead songs it's like
don't do that it's really bad okay but
had time freedom and one of the things
that I learnt the first of all I learned
was that financial freedom actually
isn't that difficult and you don't need
that many houses in order to massively
change your lifestyle how we would agree
if you would say yes yes thank you um so
I speak to some people I split I know
one guy is a personal friend of mine he
owns one hundred and eighty-five houses
now that's more houses than I earn but I
make a lot more money than he makes see
so it's not about how many houses you
own it's about what they can do so
that's my first house and I did I
traveled and did some stuff and then I
went to Bible College for three years
because I had taught I had time freedom
I spent six days a week studying
theology for three years and while I was
there I I really kind of came to the you
know I went out on two different trips
to spend some time in India and putting
job and some different places and I
thought you know what this house is
doing really well I've done some of
Simon's training and I've got one house
which is great but I don't want to rest
on my laurels forever I want to actually
now buy more houses and be able to make
a difference if that's while I was in
Zambia I met a boy who walked 14 miles
in one day to get some water 40 miles in
one day and you know what that that one
of these trips I just thought man you
know what I'm being a bit lazy here and
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna pull my
sleeves up and I'm gonna do this
property being hardcore so 19 years old
bought six more houses 21 years old had
a property million I had a million pound
property portfolio and was completely
financially free I'm now 26 in those
five months I've bought five houses
three of them have been HMOs two of them
have been lease option agreements and
I've traded over 120 properties in the
last 12 months so thank you
thank you you know so business is great
and it's exciting and I'm making lots of
money for me and some of the staff but
also last last week last week I was in
Uganda in Africa and you know I sell a
lot of time working in different rural
villages and it's great you know and I
think that is why I do want to do I also
run a network you know when I was 20 I
got kicked out of my church because they
had the mindset that the more money you
have the more poor people you must
trampled over and you know I was really
really misunderstood and I remember I
remember attending going to church one
day after having lots of jabs and quiet
meetings you know and attended church
one day and they were there was a
caretaker and one of the other standing
at the door and they said I think you
need to find somewhere new to go you
know and that was really painful for me
and as a result of that
while I was at Bible College I decided
to do my dissertation on biblical
economics and I really study actually
what does I mean I'm a Christian I don't
try and push my religious beliefs or
faith down anyone's throat but I'm a
Christian and I studied what does the
Bible say about money and actually I
came to the conclusion that money's not
good or bad it's a really good tool and
if you hold it like this we've opened
hands and a generous heart god bless you
the problem is when you start holding it
like this because everything on this
earth is leasehold you know and as I
started coming to some of these
conclusions and it really I began to
subconsciously stop sabotaging my
success and that was really what
triggered it for me as a result of that
I set up a Christian business network
for Christian business folks
nonexclusive
all welcome but where we support good
people to make lots of money they go
make a difference in the community in
across the world and that has grown to
be the largest network of its kind in
the UK we've got 14 branches we've got
staff and different people while I'm
here tonight
well every time I come and speak at Penn
I always get in your mouth afterwards
of people saying some of what you taught
and applied it and left my job or I've
just bought another couple of houses
thanks or this was so difficult but now
it's so simple and you know what that's
really rewarding I'm not paid to be here
I've come quite a long way I live in
Staffordshire and out in the country and
a lovely barn conversion I've left my
four month pregnant wife for the day to
be out here because I believe that in
the next sort of 40 minutes with some of
the strategies that we're going to go
through I really believe that there
could be some real significant
differences to some people right here so
is it okay well I've got nothing to sell
I'm here because I just want to inspire
you guys and all I ask in return is that
if something I say results in change or
some successes in your life please email
me and let me know good no that's not
good yet awesome I like you guys and if
you treat me well I'll take you with me
as my traveling audience all right so
maybe have some fun I put some so many
cool things to go through with you so
please do take lots of notes you can
have questions that's fine I will be
giving a champ hopefully the questions
at the end if we get time if I do go
over a few minutes and we started late
please feel free to leave anytime nine
onwards of a dig over a few minutes I
hope that's okay okay awesome I really
like you guys okay so you know when I
started out here when I became
successful in property and I started
getting invitations for dinner by my ex
schoolteachers and what my school kids
parents and stuff like that is really
weird and you know they wanted to deal
with my brain about what about property
and there's loads different questions
but the questions boiled down to four
questions how many questions please for
thank you for questions and the four
questions boiled down to these four
things when is the best time to buy what
about bricks it what about the new
change well that's where it is the best
time to buy next what are the best
properties to buy what should I buy next
where is the best place to buy and
Leslie had of I especially had a bike
with no money what lives in that stuff
and these can I started my money
so these were the four questions that
pretty much class the most so what we're
going to do right now is I am going to
answer best I can these four questions
is that okay now it is quite simple um
but I believe that some of you who
learned a fair bit okay now this is just
my experience who's experienced it mine
thank you and so do with this what you
must but I pray that it was every well
okay yes great stuff so um when to buy
when do you think now well the fact that
you're here with this property at this
meeting to learn how to buy more
properties would suggest that you think
now why why not was not at the time
it's what sorry it's always more
expensive later what a beautifully well
put way give her a hand that's so true
it's always more expensive later that's
right um what else why is now a good
time to invest because we're sorry
there's money to be made right now
absolutely yeah well yes yeah people are
selling out because of the changes in
the market that's right what about the
changes in the market though what about
brexit what do we think are we scared
about break six one up plenty man yeah
yeah what about any tax changes
opportunity I like you guys okay I'm in
the right room um absolutely you guys
already know that I'm not going to spend
too much time my personal beliefs I've
been investing almost ten years and I
mean I'm young but I've looked back at
history a long way and history tends to
do what blues repeat itself and I
personally think right now in 2017 I
think it's the best time to invest in
property than it has been in a very long
time that's what I believe why do I
believe that now is the time to invest
in property
well you guys have kind of already said
it in fact mr. Zhu Shi he says in his
book that properties double in value
every he says seven to nine years
sometimes people say only things every
selling is on exhibit ten years okay
fine so I put 10 on here okay but the
point is that over time properties
increase in value true or true true
thank you and I mean you know what we're
on a small island which limited paddlers
this is a business supply and demand
your house is your product and your
tenant is your customer and there's
people were literally fighting to try
and get into this country we've got
protected lands everywhere we've got a
shortage of housing and we've got an
overpopulation of people so to say the
properties are not going to go will be a
little bit stupid especially based on
history and guess what after recession
comes expansion and a few expansion
comes what recession absolutely and
we've had over the last sort of 10 years
on the main a pretty big what recession
thank you so that probably means that on
the way I is what yeah that is already
happening so I think I think it's early
it's a great time to invest in property
but you guys already know that so let's
move on real quick so when when we buy
now you need to say it like you mean it
guys come on I've come a long way
when do we buy No thank you I get a bit
excited about this stuff because you
know this is um life-changing stuff so
now but next what do we buy ok um ok let
me let me show you something really
interesting this completely changed my
life and how I saw economics and stuff
like that I walk back so check this out
bank if you put money in the bank you're
going to get a high return investment or
a low return on investment low return on
investment how low part of a set and
would that be considered good prop about
half percent yeah so let's say you're
going to put money in the bank because I
remember when I used to with the kiddos
think I want to put money in the bank
and I want there to be so much money I
can live off the interest of stupids
that how much really going to need I
mean let's say you put money in the bank
let us say you port in the bank
50,000 pound which is a fair sum of
money that's a fair similarly you put
50,000 pounds in the back and your
interest on that I mean is going to be a
picture of systems yes so let's let's
say you put 50 grand in the bank and you
wait a real long time and you leave the
interest to accumulate and you what you
have to work an awful long time let's
say you wait 10 years okay at six ten
years of waiting to see what happens to
your fifty thousand pounds your fifty
thousand pounds where we worth
approximately how much 75 someone said
if you advance it on 55 no fifteen and a
half guys your fifty thousand pounds of
cheese would be probably around about
thirty six thousand pounds how so
inflation as cost of living goes up but
the money stays the same the money
becomes worth less over time check this
out
moneyed appreciates in value I did this
presentation to a group of bankers a few
months ago I was pretty scared I was
like if you put your money in the back
oh I said up to ten years and what
suppose I said to touch you I didn't
even give tap dancing either yeah it
will be
I'm not really planning no not on this
all my [ __ ] so I was like that's
pretty sick and they were like yeah
they know this stuff course I'll give
you an example
I'm going to depreciate in value like
because some of the back getting a glass
of water that'd be wonderful okay ten
years ago if you were a millionaire 20
20 years ago them also 20 years ago if
you are millionaire bravo Bravo
today in 2017 everybody's a millionaire
why because a million pounds today it's
worth a lot less than it was five 10 20
years ago make sense yes well when I say
how many of you know ask a lot of
questions yes the reason is because if I
ask you a question like does that make
sense
and you kind of go I'm gonna have to do
it and keep going and on and on and on
on the point but if you go get make
sense I can then move on so if we want
to put it 10 plus 9 that's cool if you
want to finish it 12 midnight then just
keep quiet is that okay yes thank you
right so 50,000 pounds put it in the
bank you wait 10 years if there were 36
thousand pounds because money shrinks in
value over time however if you put that
same 50 thousand pounds into a house and
you wait the same 10 years how much is
it fifty thousand pounds going to be
worth 100 thousand no
here's the thing check this out the
rents are not even including Lance
forget rents I said added bonus here's
the thing unless you bought the house
for cash tell me is that the depository
that leak is that yeah what most people
would probably tend to get a mortgage
from our beautiful mortgage guy at the
back so tell me tell me what doubles in
value the deposit on the house or the
value of the house value correct so you
put down 50,000 pounds on houses worth
about 200 yet you eight ten years and
after ten years it's increased to how
much four hundred thousand pounds we
call this leverage and that my friends
is how most people get rich that's it ed
you ever played cashflow one I want no
it's a game with Robert Kiyosaki made it
up and you can buy houses and different
things that you try to become
financially free and the way to win if
you've known if you've played this game
you'll know is to buy a few houses and
then you'll begin a bit passive income
and it's all going okay okay I'm getting
it let's think a minute suddenly
inflation out so the houses go up in
value and boom you sell one you buy
loads more and you become financially
independent that's how most people get
rich and that is also this is I mean you
could have the same two people you could
have who went to the same school live on
the same street mode the same they're
not made the same wife
he's everything best friends from school
that has the same qualifications have
the same job and the same paycheck and
save the same amount of money each month
folks a fifty thousand pounds one puts
fifty thousand pounds in a house one
puts it in the back one is that rich
what is it broke and that is why
communism doesn't work I don't make up
the rules but this is the truth make
sense yes so we love to what to buy
I mean seriously some people can get
really kind of like aren't scared of Oh
watching what the wrong property and you
can buy the wrong property but pretty
much I think I mean Julia is brand-new
to property okay so say you're brand new
did you first time at Penn I can see
with some the line right okay she burst
on my pin and if you go any properties
currently great okay Sophia imagine if
right now I blindfolded Sophia I took it
to the nearest train station where the
nearest train station where Bush Bush
pre-assess that's near where are their
bushy okay this is this story is getting
really weird now
bushy all right I take another train
station blindfolded anti-drug er okay
and so this is not a true story
don't worry champ I've appointed story
alright serious um and and I spin around
and I put her on the train and she's
like and she falls asleep and she wakes
up and she has no idea what day it is or
what time it is no idea she has no idea
what city she even isn't she could be
back in bushy or she could be um in
Scotland she have absolutely no idea
where she is she gets off the train and
then I lead her body harm into the
nearest estate agents she walked into an
estate gauges blindfolded she knows that
was the board here of houses she touches
it she goes
mister estate agent that one okay and
the estate agent says I'm what do you
mean that one's yours I mean I want to
buy that house and they say uh but you
can't even see it and she says I know
but I just heard a presentation about
houses doubling in value and I want to
buy that house and they said you know no
the asking price is you don't know how
much you're gonna buy it for you can't
even see it and she says I will pay the
asking price
imagine that happen would you be smart
or would should be stupid smart stupid
all right well Sophia let me show you
what happen if you did that okay
what's the average house price in the UK
240 to do this presentation up north and
they say forty ground okay I do hear
you're like Mara 250 is 300 average
average I tell you the average house
price if you pens how you work out the
average if you use the mean the mode or
the median but the average is one click
spot in the UK you can check it out but
that sounds feasible yes thank you so if
you buy a house for 165 Sophia you're
going to have to put a deposit right on
a roundabout usually about 25% now you
can't pay a lot less than that if you
have a really good broker but 25% is
about standards because is this fair yes
right so you going to put down 25% and
25% of one six five is how much oh wow
Samuel you're beautiful okay it's gonna
make a nice really hard in a minute
isn't it okay so that's the deposit so
that time what you're gonna put that
okay just on the deposit of course
you're going to have a few legal fees
and different stuff and bits and bobs
we're going to try and keep this a
little bit simple for a second okay yes
so 41 to 15 is the deposit and then your
mortgage payment
wow that's the mortgage yeah this goes
do it okay so if you take that c-123 750
that's right left them outstanding
mortgage that's your debt you're gonna
have to pay probably have what
percentage on it on a normal body to let
problem so how much between two three
percent so also three percent is that
fair yes so what's three percent of one
two three 750 Samuel
oh there was me thinking sit on his head
what you what what is it
monthly actually yearly whatever 370
fifty per month Oh 309 pounds is the
monthly mortgage payment is that right
yes
how much if average went on a 165 house
in the UK
eight hundred a thousand six hundred
okay so she a little bit less it's
actually average rent is 775 sound
feasible yes yes thank you
so now I never lose a few of the little
bit some of the costs low you're going
to be insurance and different stuff like
that okay but I'm no mathematician but
if your monthly rent is 775 and your
mortgage payments of 309 you're in
profit yes
so let's say I mean in this occasion
three three four five six seven
you're like four hundred and fifty odd
pound a month in profit but you're all
going to have a few expenses of course
you can have a few are you have you
staff a Tuesday and things like that so
let's be fair about this so let's say
you put down a total of fifty thousand
and you make per month four hundred
pounds is that is that about fair great
you tell me because you're obviously all
investors all mostly so you put down how
much move fifty and that's your
investment and then you're getting back
how much please
four hundred per month which is how much
bigger four thousand eight hundred and
that's your annual profit which means
that your return on investment is about
nine and a half percent true so your
mate so you bought a house blindfolded
but it's not absurd good
so if I was blindfolded from a random
estate agent and you don't even look at
it and what would probably happen based
on averages is you'd beginning around
about nine and a half percent return on
investment and your property would be
going up in value and it would be
leveraged as well pretty good yeah so
imagine what would happen if she bought
a house without a blind daughter if she
can get ten percent return and obviously
all the capital appreciation everything
winehouse blindfolded imagine what'll
happen if she bought a house with a
bottle imagine what would happen if
Sophia bought a house not blindfolded
and had just done some training and
talked to some investors and they've got
a strategy together Wow she could rock
take over the world so what we're going
to do right now is we're going to talk
about how to bring that 9.5% up to more
like 25-30 percent good so if I can show
you how to make 30 percent return on
investment quite comfortably quite
easily would that be a worthwhile
presentation yes thank you
right so so we're going to play a little
game and this game is fun
but also educational Oh everybody for
the chef's you're not really ready for
this yes all right here we go so I'm
going to show a couple of houses both
houses are mine and I just want to
pretend that we're auctioning out and
I'm going to say um which house do you
want and you're going to tell me which
one you want to go so these are the two
houses there's this one and there's this
one and guys do you want the bushy one
or the dirty one oh my god oh wow this
you can't read dodgy I'm join that's one
on the right one this one's the last one
this one is the right one left all right
right so you've got no questions before
you buy which ones where it may say
joint if I may pass
all right you got questions yes all
right all right what I'm going to do is
I'm going to give you a chance to ask
you questions so in fact it all say your
questions together at the same time one
two three oh wow you are some of you
kind of went out with your betters no
announcements walk in so this title that
you all to answer a question and
whichever one I happen to hear the
loudest I will answer and we're going to
pretend to will so this is a real life
you know you've got one question a
nominal answer to it and then you have
to buy one so don't you know try be
clever and say silly things what are you
actually going to ask if I'm going to
say to you which one Nomad to one
question that's it and then after I've
answer that question you have to buy one
and make a decision
what is that one question you're going
to ask okay so think about it hard and
one two three go
oh wow oh wow hold on hold on hold on
this was at all wow that was like a real
you all answered but I didn't hear one
who's down in question so hey what his
or George is the fairest wife who is new
tonight okay um all right Suzanne I feel
the connection already all right Suzanne
did you ask your question a moment ago
and you'll know what was your question
what's that
where is it very good give her a hand
very good who else is nerd ah okay ah
Ellie what was your question
what's the rental payments give her a
hand your hand and then one more
question all right who's no yes
whooshing what's your name evil and what
was your question what's the potential I
like it give her a hand
also they've got a few questions and
we're going to go through a second and
look at those now um so you're actually
going to buy it
come on well you always say I'm going to
say to you right I'm going to answer
that question I would say what the
potentials unless you got to buy it what
you want to before you buy it
what do you want know how much the price
yeah so you got lots of questions so
here it will go to I'm going to answer I
did a survey with over 900 investors and
they asked all those a different
question
some of them said what's the potential
some said what's the ransom said what's
the garden like some sir what's the
neighbor's dog like son said how much
some said where is it something what
street some could he leave the text or
since it is everywhere drug dealing
before its load aggressive but the top
two questions that they asked because
that's know what they is the top two
questions that I ever serve over 900
investors to talk to your questions with
this the first one was what you reckon
which one would I buy you know yeah in
fact you know what this house this house
I lived in it for a week in January and
the BBC BBC one came and filmed it cuz
they were so intrigued so that'll be on
over the summer nine o'clock prime time
because you want anyway um okay so the
two questions are another one question
which was asked by over 900 investors
whoa
what how much is it yes so I'll tell you
this one's 110
this one's 160 number 2 question 1
they're actually gonna buy it now it is
and they will know where is it yes
so whoopsie this one's in County Durham
this one's in which one do you want
having uh but this one this one has a
castle nearby okay know what um here's
the lesson in this okay we have loads
loads difference when buying properties
when I'm buying properties I have one
leaving question I want to know before
buying the house and that question is
and you said it early that is I want to
know
well think about this okay a property's
supposed to be an asset yes you're
buying it as an investment and asset is
what let me Kiyosaki says an asset is
something that puts money into your butt
back pocket every single most yes so
that there are the asset it means the
mall what money will go into your back
pocket via what means rent so I will
agree to the first question I wanna know
before I know even where it is or what
cover the front door is or even how much
it is the first question all I know is
how much
how to get from this house does that
make sense so for instance in this
occasion in fact here's the really funny
part the 900 investors when they have
this information now you guys are
obviously well-educated because you've
got a brilliant pin host Michelle and
you've some of you've got some
experience and you've probably read
climate issues book but most people most
professional investors at this point
said that they would be more inclined to
go for this one why because it's cheap
and it's pretty this one is expensive I
know not for you cuz you're from London
but this one is expensive and it's ugly
yeah this one gives me four hundred
pounds on one friend and this one gives
me 1,500 pounds on my friends so the key
is to go in and find well what is the
return on investment going to be now
this is quite straightforward I know but
there's so many invested Amex so many
people let's say on buying a house I'll
say how great wet Liverpool and why
Liverpool or because my son was moving
to university to live in Liverpool ok I
know I thought it might be our you know
kill two birds and then don't buy
property to kill two birds okay like 101
a property investing don't try and kill
two birds or you know oh I'm buying this
house I just had a really nice feeling
about it guess what professional
investors buy with formulas not feelings
agreed formulas not feelings so what are
the formulas and how do we establish you
know how do we get properties with a
high return well firstly you know what
personally if I'm going to property 416
is giving me 1500 rent I don't really
care where it is that much you know I
mean some people get really obsessed
with we think we'll get that okay
firstly don't get emotionally involved
okay
it doesn't matter Bates feeling he
doesn't matter about you know I think
this was me actually when I my second
house fell through when the mortgage
Express went bust and I could no longer
buy my house of refinancing the next day
and the deal fell through ah
and I learnt this discipline your
disappointment I'd already learnt to
celebrate my success
that's very important but discipline you
disappointment discipline your feelings
investments are not for show my friend
owns both these houses gets how much
this what makes him a month's profit
hundred fifty-pound a month this one -
fifty pound a month these are just a
handful of mine this one makes me a
thousand pounds profit a month
this one 950 this one about 800 but
they're really ugly
yeah the ugly houses are usually the
best it's about formulas not feelings I
mean here is I've got different formers
if you go through with you but you know
what we haven't got too long together
okay so instead I'm just going to
summarize all the different formulas
that I have into a poem I made this poem
up while I was at PIN
what's the pin I just made it up you
know adlib made this poem up and I got a
standing ovation now not expecting a
standing ovation or anything but would
you live in the poem yes you don't want
to hear it come on we'd like to live
poem yes all right here we go it goes
like this
okay it's real deep summarizes my
philosophy of property investing in a
couple sentences which rhymes here we go
buy low rent high with a property
manager nearby thank you you know I mean
seriously I mean here's the interesting
thing okay if you buy a house for a
hundred thousand pounds and the rent is
seven hundred and then you buy a house
for two hundred thousand pounds well the
rent be double because of those double
no here's a thing there's no correlation
between the value of the house and the
rental value of the house okay now this
is really interesting because I rent a
lot of rooms out I rent a lot of HMOs
and multi rates and I've learned
something really interesting and that is
this if I buy a house in Bush
all for 350,000 pounds the rooms will
went out for about 400 pounds each if I
buy the same house in Birmingham or
Wolverhampton or stoke-on-trent or Darby
I'll pay about a hundred thousand for it
which is like almost a quarter of the
price but the rent will go from 400 to
350 buy low rent high oh but I don't
want to buy in Darby because I live in
Bristol and it needs to be near my area
because I need to dominate my ground I
don't know you know what you know what
this is what I paint in whose opinion my
opinion okay and my opinion is this it's
that it's I'm I mean I spent the whole
of October in Africa I spent the whole
of November in California I spent the
whole of December in Thailand I got back
then went round Europe and different
places does it matter if the house is in
Bristol or if it is Scotland No why not
because I'm not going to manage it
anyway people say I need to be within
about 45 minutes just in case there's a
problem guess what that's a really bad
plan a it's just a closed to the public
needs to be near my house that means
it's not financial freedom that means
it's a rope around your neck
shrila trip I know some of you now maybe
seem a little bit I just felt the air
leave the room you know um but the thing
is if you have systems in place you can
buy anywhere but this is good news okay
I don't want this to be like oh I wish
good news because it means it liberates
you to buy anywhere you want anywhere
you want as long as you've got a
property manager or a penalty in the
area does this make sense yes so by
lowering high property managers nearby
if I could just say one thing that will
pretty much be it what kind of
properties do I buy how do I get that
kind of return in fact let me just I'll
just give you a little example of
something right here you know when I
gave you an example here the house that
was 165 thousand pounds with a rent of
how much seven seven five I mean would
it be right if I talked about the last
house that I bought okay is that okay
yes
all right left out to the ball
seventy-nine thousand pound was the
purchase price which means that the
closet is a lot less but deposits how
much about twenty thousand tiny bit left
for the deposit which means my mortgage
payments are much less how much
well my mortgage is about when you're
fifty a month yeah I'm actually 162 so
pretty much bang on mortgage payment per
month and I went on a 79 grand house how
much five hundred thirteen hundred
pounds that's the last house that I
bought and you know what it completed
six weeks ago and I'm already getting
that rent
good or good I'll but of course to us
yeah you know you can't work out the
returns on that because of course
there's going to be a refurb and things
like that yes so this is this is a
multi-layer HMO and I mentioned out it's
basically got to reception rooms and
it's got four bedrooms though so to
assess rooms and three bedrooms and I'm
rent in each room out to 350 and this
room right here it was a reception room
but I turned it into a bedroom and then
I rented out also for 350 and the refurb
on this house how much do you reckon to
turn you know a 79 grand house into a
HTML 5 grand 25:10
four and a half thousand pounds so very
close Maria four and half thousand
pounds my builder lied to me in the
early days my builder told me that
average HMA you're talking fifty
thousand pounds that's what you said you
know what you know how I turn to
accentuate till they dream you know what
it's quite it just take some complex
accomplished this is a nod to gets
treated to do to turn it we set you into
a bedroom we need to do is you need to
put a ban on it this is not complicated
stuff you know it's serious so for our
thousand pounds five little smoke alarms
a little bit of carpet and paint and
boom it's beautiful you know what if you
saw the house you feel like wow it's
like a joke it's like a hotel inside
beautiful absolutely beautiful so what's
my return on investment well twenty
thousand pound deposit plus four and a
half thousand pounds plus my stamp duty
my legals and everything he actually
ended up also I did furnish it as well
and the furniture was like amazing all
in you're talking about it was about is
about 32,000 pounds okay for everything
yeah so 32,000 pounds is my upfront
investment and my annual profit is
pretty much what I usually do keep
things simple with a HMO or a multi let
your rent half of it is out the window
straight away on expenses what are you
expensive yacht in my case three hundred
pounds on my bills two hundred pound on
my management fees 162 on my mortgage
payments and then a little bit just for
insurance and stuff like that so it
works out to be seven hundred pounds and
that's including all the management all
the bells all the mortgage payments
which leaves me with seven hundred
pounds a month which is per year eight
thousand four hundred eight thousand
four hundred is my profit each year to
work out the return on investment you
take the profit each year and you divide
it by the deposit and if you do that
Samuel it comes down to how much twenty
six point two five percent good yes any
questions on that before we move on
oh you know what I said I had four
questions I think I'll have time to
answer three of them and the next one is
where is it was the low dose you don't
want to know you like the runners all
right Bristol no Busch you're pushy all
right I'll tell where it is you know in
fact let's do it p10 a bit background
right now okay why don't I start out
investing my first time start bought was
in this little place in Birmingham you
see my builder he lied to me he told me
they're the only area that works for
mall - actually this little place called
horville when I made the chocolate
covering he said you see London is the
biggest city in the UK its capital
promises London it is really frickin
expensive maybe buy in London you're not
going to get the returns the second
biggest is probably Birmingham
Birmingham is also expensive but much
cheaper from the thinkers of Birmingham
is the north is cheap and tacky the
South is expensive the middle is just
flat but right outside the middle a few
miles away this little place called
Bournville with the train station which
can gate take you straight to the centre
and it's brilliant it's the gold mine
it's the areas of HMOs guess where we
lived although you did you lived in
vaudeville my friend went and bought a
house similar to my little one what the
first one I showed you showed you that I
bought and we financed make him rent
from about yay my friend went in bought
a house so I bought the first one in
vaudeville second one in Bothell third
one just outside of one of them my bill
doesn't she just about education next
time come little bit close to border I
know a friend when I bought one in
Wolverhampton shed for Hampton now at
the time I was like 18 years old and I'm
seniors I was a teenager so still
getting experience some stuff so I was
managing his properties for him to
really just immerse myself in HMOs and
properties I said I don't think I'm
gonna vote to rent out your rooms in
Wolverhampton he said Oh careful else I
said well you know I think I want to
struggle that's all because it's light
importable you seen London's with the
because runs a little earlier he said
it's fine some if you wanna manage you
find if not - it's not I'll go get a
good but don't come to me if I don't
rent the rooms out he said it's fine
here's housing will mountain the rooms
rented out for faster
for more money than mine in Louisville
and he bought the houses for cheaper I
said wow there's two areas that work
right demos and then I found the truth
of it and this is the truth of it you
ready for this is actually I'll list the
areas that where people are looking for
notes okay give me for this giveaway
I only take this down yeah okay it's
said they're looking for HMOs everywhere
anything with someone no mr. Tate
Liverpool guess what there are people
right now looking for rooms in Liverpool
so when I remember saying Manchester's
people looking in Manchester's kids I
can wash it we get some food I mean I'm
going to prove this way now I'm making
my phone I'm gonna go through the
website called spare room code on UK and
spell room doctor do UK pramana doesn't
know it is in a website where people
advertise themself a young professionals
and say hey look you've a room and we'll
go in the rooms around
okay now I'm Tobias you can be more
witness you can try and make my life
hard right now you can name the worst
city you can think of where surely that
is the third chick there no one's
looking for a roof and you watch
there'll be people looking for rooms and
their budget will be around about 350
pounds a month do you know why because
their budget doesn't really change so
someone now in a city in England
Chesterfield is that chest owes up the
city Chester
okay we'll do it justice what you said
first stop in Chester we can do darby's
I have a topping Chester and then type
in looking for rooms or look you know
yeah never not search the room search
potential people looking for rooms yeah
hold on hold on don't tell me anything
that's amazing just look for people
searching for rooms yes don't tell me
anything hold on hold on I'm thinking
I'm gonna make a prediction have you
done it okay
guys guys sorry it's my fault it's my
it's my fault I should have picked him
yes
so it's flatmates okay and then don't
say anything just press it okay all
right I'll make a prediction new today
in Chester new today and how much they
look at the page month and it's that
enemies logo and if so how much 325 and
then there's another one how much and
then another one ninety per week not
you'd be a week and then other alright
left oranges and then there's what pages
and pages are people move today look in
the room thank you someone a new city
Newcastle sup in Newcastle we're good to
Susan this is the last time so they've
got really bad city don't wander Stoke
well would you want to put I don't you
can choose it's probably a bad one okay
alright and then put some flatmates how
many people what's going on new today oh
yeah new day new day new day new to say
yeah lives don't its pages pages while
we've been in this meeting there's been
people looking for Rosie and Lucas that
one guess what their budget is around
about how much three sister
interesting so that is what my strategy
I'm thinking what hold on a minute if
there's people looking for rooms
everywhere and their budgets kind of the
same wouldn't it make sense to find a
city where by the house you know cheap
well by I can read the rooms out like
this
via find a hatch of our manager in the
area and we're into our I mean serious
and you know what you can say that
sounds good in theory but what about in
practice that's what I do
and to put my money where my mouth is
sort of this one guy in one of the
meetings that I was at about six months
ago I could name a city and anyway Stoke
stoke-on-trent
he said he said ghost town
and I wait okay we did the game huh a
minute and there's about three people
knew that day I was like man it today it
kind of worked and this house William
Stokoe and I'm getting that and I think
even one or two people from the room
might have even seen the house I'm now
taking some people up then you've been
out in the area and you've seen the kind
of houses if that were me and Ben were
out together we clinched the lease
option agreement on the spot right I
haven't got time to go into too much
more details as it's been useful I've
got a couple minutes left so I'm going
to just try and give you another couple
nuggets before we close beef you know if
anyone they don't want more info on this
kind of stuff I have put together a
video series all right which I'll
mention at the end which is basically me
and a flip chart and my wife filming not
this flip job a flip chart looks just
like this and my wife filmed me and I go
into a lot more detail over some of this
stuff also below his bed might he's led
my book oh wow not as famous as a fall
okay man come on man help me out here
buddy
all right
yeah that I've got a book on Amazon I've
sold 25,000 copies in the last three
months and it's great I'd recommend
reading it all right where to buy where
do we buy anywhere absolutely anywhere
well what about other some areas is
oversaturated you know what and they're
all some areas where you can't buy
because of my the article for or or
different reasons but in regards to just
remember this is a business and it's
about supply and demand
just just remember that and this
although there's others more more levels
doing HMOs yes there are but there's
more more attendants what did you have
rooms as well alright so yeah how do you
buy there are ways where you can buy
with no money you know I wish I had
longer but I am going to have to wrap up
but as I say I've done two Lease Option
agreements in the last five months there
have been no money down deals Lease
Option agreements are they're incredible
you get buy now pay later but with a
house you don't want to do buy now pay
later of anything else we did of a car
you agreed to pay the price down the
line you buy it now and then in five
years when you go
by your bullet on man I'm paying over
the odds now where the house opposite
green now and later boom and you've got
all the money monthly as well so if
anyone would be interested in receiving
the videos in fact you know what I love
pin I said I'm going to suddenly think
which I'm not so his what his all say
and anybody's right now today from pin
it would like to see the videos save my
voice because what usually happens is
people call me a lot of these events
anyone is interested can have access to
them for free good thank you
also if you don't the copy of the book
you know what I'm really sorry I the
book which is by low-rent hi I was
supposed to bring some tonight but I
completely forgot so I'm really sorry so
if you would like to copy the book I
would also be happy to gifted that to
anybody for free as well
good and you know when I do that I said
bit at the beginning I love pin summers
you she got me into property he cheating
changed my life I come here because I
want to hear the success stories and I'm
really busy I'm a director of a charity
full time and nonprofit organization I'm
really busy but I didn't want to leave a
legacy I do want to help as many people
as I can to be successful in property so
all I would say if you would like to
receive access to the video series and
also receive a free copy of the it'll be
a hard copy but a kinder learn it's a
hard copy sent to you in the post all
you do just drop me a text this is my
personal phone number if you ring it I
will answer all my PA will answer if you
text me I'll find it it's my personal
number just let me know who you are and
also where you want me to send the
videos over to celebrity you name an
email and what I'll do is I'll send you
all the videos and I'll also send you a
copy of the book now there's two
conditions one is if you read the book
and like it let me know leave a review
on Amazon or something like that
secondly the book is a gift from me but
I do ask that you text me tonight
because if I'm in Uganda or even worse
if I'm in the bath in two weeks time and
I'm a she's not
and my phone just read what I'll leave
it no no I get out of bath and I look
like one of you guys texted me about the
book and the videos guess what that's
getting deleted all right
say yes all right serious if you want it
do text me tonight okay makes my life so
much easier
idealist because whether you pay for the
PMP for the book but the book is a gift
videos you love them so ladies gentlemen
thank you so much for your time
god bless you and I'll see you soon
thank you
[Applause]